a few minutes before a trans identified
woman named Audrey hail murdered three
9-year-old children and three adults in
a Christian school in Nashville
Tennessee hail sent a private message to
one of her friends on social media hail
said quote one day this will make more
sense I've left more than enough
evidence behind now obviously that
message was an admission that hail's
motivations were written down in a place
where investigators could easily find
them and yet as of early yesterday
morning more than seven months after
hail committed this Mass murder the
public was not allowed to see any of
that evidence that Audrey Hill said she
left Behind law enforcement agencies
including the FBI the Tennessee Bureau
of Investigation concealed it these
agencies admitted that they were in
possession of a Manifesto and other
documents they occasionally summarized
portions of the material for reporters
and at various points they suggested
that they might release them for public
consumtion but they never did wasn't
hard to guess why authorities might want
to suppress this information clearly the
manifesto contained writings that the
people in charge saw as a threat to
their own legitimacy otherwise why
wouldn't they release it almost
certainly the manifesto demonstrated
that the left sustained attacks on their
own chosen enemies were having their
intended effect but without the
documents themselves we had no way of
knowing the extent of the deception
that's been taking place for the better
part of a year and what exactly the
government was hiding and why exactly
they were hiding it well all of that
changed abruptly and without warning a
little over 24 hours ago when Steven
Crowder posted several pages from what
he said was a notebook that belonged to
Audrey hill and in those 24 hours
neither the FBI nor Tennessee officials
have contested the validity of Crowder's
documents so uh they have all but
confirmed uh indirectly that they are
authentic and that's worth
restating it was Steven Crowder not the
law enforcement agencies that we fund
with our tax dollars and that are sworn
to Serve and Protect US who finally
provided some some transparency into one
of the worst mass shootings in recent
history already that seems like it's a
rather damning indictment of the doj and
of the Tennessee bu Bureau investig of
Investigation uh and uh and it's it's
bad enough
already but it gets worse and first a
quick point of clarification the
manifesto that Crowder published is not
the entirety of hail's writings it's
just a short uh excerpt included in the
journal are lines like this quote kill
those kids those crackers going to
private fancy schools with those fancy
khakis F you want to kill all you little
crackers bunch of little gay slur that
begins with f with your white privileges
I wish to shoot you weak expletives with
your mop yellowed
hair now there's more to it than that
but just take some of those lines in
isolation for a second and want to kill
all you little crackers says the mass
shooter who clearly is upset about quote
white privileges with those quotes in
mind let's let's take a look back at
what the director of the Tennessee
Bureau of Investigation a man named
David Rous was saying about the
manifesto back in April watch it's been
characterized as a Manifesto I think
that's a mischaracterization personally
um the the documents that we have and I
have viewed those uh you know one is
specifically a plan uh and the other is
is some uh Journal type rantings uh but
nothing you know when you talk about
Manifesto you talk about something
similar to like the uniom are left
behind ideological Expressions uh that
that none of that has has has surfaced
in these writings it's really um
unfortunate uh mental health issues that
are that that that you can see uh as you
read through uh the the the
journals so there's uh two sets of
documents says David Rous there is a
plan plus Journal type rantings he
clarifies that nothing Audrey hail wrote
approaches the uh the depth of the
unibomber manifesto for example which
seems fair enough not surprising but
then he goes on he says that hail's
Manifesto doesn't contain quote
ideological Expressions instead he says
that only unfortunate mental health
issues are
evident now this is among other things a
scandal because now that portions of
this Manifesto have been published we
can reasonably conclude that the head of
Tennessee's top investigative agency has
been misleading the public for months he
was suggesting that somehow it's not an
ideological expression to say that white
children should die because they have
white
privilege that can't possibly be a
reflection of some deeply held
ideological belief says David Roush it
has to be a sign of mental illness and
nothing more now to be as Fair as
possible to Rous it's possible that you
know if we see every other page of the
Manifesto or of the journal typew
writings whatever you want to call it
doesn't matter and we see all of that
and all the other documents then when we
look at all of it in its
totality maybe we come conceivably to
different conclusions how different what
conclusions well we don't know without
seeing all the documents there is some
uncertainty admittedly but it's not our
fault that that uncertainty is
there and indeed that has been the
defense that we've seen pop up in the
media that there's more to it that all
this is being selectively
leaked all yesterday a self-described
investigative reporter at News Channel 5
named Phil Williams was essentially
running cover for the FBI on this story
he lashed out at Maga keyboard Warriors
as he called them he also insisted that
stepen Crowder was misleading the public
by only releasing a few pages of the
Killer's Journal quote multiple sources
have told me that selective uh leak of
the three pages of the Covenant School
shooting Manifesto is extremely
misleading people who have read the
whole thing say there's something in
there for everybody another says she
hated everybody and he went on and on
posting arguments like that all day but
there's an obvious response to this
whole line of argument which is this if
it's true that Crowder released as they
say misleading portions of the manifesto
then there's a very easy solution give
us the full story release the whole
thing when the government refuses to be
honest when they don't tell the whole
truth we are left to speculate and fill
in the
gaps that's especially true given that
for the past several months Rous and the
Tennessee Bureau of Investigation
repeated their misleading claims about
the manifesto over and over again all
the while refusing to produce the
manifesto itself so that the public
could actually make their own
determination about what it says and
everything else for example back in
April uh News Channel 5 reported on
roush's meetings with um Tennessee
sheriffs and according to News Channel 5
quote Rous said that uh that what police
found isn't so much a Manifesto spelling
out a Target but a series of RAM Ling
writings indicating no clear motive Rous
told sheriffs that the review so far of
the material finds that the killer did
not write about specific political
religious or social issues in fact a
primary focus in the journals is on
idolizing those who committed prior
school
shootings to the extent authorities
offered any motive whatsoever it was
that hail had some personal problem with
the school that she once attended as NBC
News reported more than two weeks uh
after the shooting quote authorities
initially believed the shooter might
hold resentment toward her former school
but they have not provided any details
so the authorities in Tennessee had no
problem implying that Audrey halil's
school might bear some responsibility
for this shooting there was a lot of
speculation online if you remember at
the time that Audrey hail had been uh
mistreated somehow by somebody at the
Covenant School and uh and that was a
speculation it's because of leaks like
this one the police had no issue with
spreading those
rumors but they somehow forgot to
mention the fact that hail wrote about
killing white people because of the
color of their skin
that went completely
unmentioned so again remember from the
authorities there were details about
these writings that were leaked out to
the public or just stated
outright but this detail they never
mentioned why is that a few other
important details went unmentioned also
in the documents published by Crowder
Audrey hail mentions that she filmed a
10-minute final video before the
massacre Hill also mentions quote there
were several times that could have been
caught especially back in the summer of
2021 now what does any of that refer to
does the FBI have a 10-minute video of
Audrey Hill elaborating on her motives
did law enforcement investigate her back
in 2021 and conclude that she wasn't a
threat I don't know but these are
important questions but the FBI and
Tennessee officials are refusing to
answer any of them Ian is this a big
part of the reason why they didn't want
to release hail's writings along with
being ideologically inconvenient do they
implicate law enforcement for fail
failing to prevent this attack did did
law enforcement have a chance to prevent
it and then
failed again we can only speculate that
that's the theme Here
speculation in fact yesterday the FBI uh
told my producers that they're refusing
to comment on Audrey hail's entire case
they they have nothing to say whatsoever
they won't say a single thing why well
because there's pending litigation
against them that's the answer they gave
now to understand what a laughable
justification that is consider that the
litigation they're talking about is a
lawsuit that was filed because the FBI
was stonewalling journalists and their
initial request for information the
lawsuit was filed by the Tennessee star
and other entities in Federal District
Court the litigation stands to unearth
the entire Audrey Audrey Hill Manifesto
in addition to any other Communications
or directives that state officials of
Tennessee might have received from the
Biden Administration merri Garland's doj
is is fighting that lawsuit claiming
there's a pending enforcement proceeding
that prevents them from releasing the
manifesto but that's that's nonsense of
course because the government can't
point to any enforcement proceeding in
this matter whatsoever and that's
because Audrey hail is dead so who is
the enforcement proceeding targeting
exactly she was killed by the police
officers who ran into the school and
shot her at Great risk to their own
lives no accomplices have been
identified in the past seven months much
less brought up before enforcement
proceedings
but this is the excuse we're hearing not
just from the FBI but from from local
police also and local officials in
Nashville they're all saying that they
can't release the writings because the
writings are the subject of litigation
except that the litigation is over the
fact that they won't release the
writings so they could release the
writings and end the
litigation their excuse is not only
absurd but insulting to our
intelligence so what's going on here
exactly think of it this way if the
Biden Administration for whatever reason
wanted to mock the deaths of Christians
and make it very clearly that only
left-wing activists are entitled to the
protection of the rule of law what
exactly would they be doing differently
recall that it was just 3 days after the
men women and children were executed in
the Covenant School when the White House
issued a proclamation about a
transgender day of visibility ability
the proclamation lamented the quote
epidemic of violence against transgender
women and girls in particular women and
girls of color the White House went on
to talk about a shooting at a nightclub
called Club Q that happened a year
earlier that was supposedly an instance
of
anti-lgbtq magga Republican violence
even though the shooter in that case if
you might remember identified as
non-binary classic Maga Republican
voting block I guess the point is Club Q
was on the mind of the White House in
late March of this year they were
thinking about that shooting in November
of of 2022 as for the Christian children
who were massacred in in a few day a few
days earlier in March of 2023 well they
were barely
mentioned and certainly they didn't get
a whole Proclamation from the White
House the Biden Administration was not
openly mourning them instead Karen Jee
perir took to the podium to explain that
the real victims of all this are
so-called trans children watch and we've
been very clear about these anti-lgbtq
bills that we're seeing in state
legislators legislator across the
country in particular these anti-trans
bills as they attack trans kids as they
attack trans parents uh it is it is
shameful and it is unacceptable uh as
you mentioned tomorrow's trans
visibility day on a day that we should
be lifting up our trans kids our trans
Youth and making sure that they feel
seen we're seeing more and more of these
hateful hateful
bills that's an incredible clip and
there are many more like it you probably
remember this footage of the left-wing
activist who stormed the Tennessee State
house shortly after the killings of the
Covenant school and they were holding up
seven fingers in remembrance of seven
victims at the Covenant School including
Audrey hail as a victim watch every
death is a tragedy y'all Seven
Lives I'd say there were seven
victims
yes seven victims because the uh the the
woman who murdered all those people is a
victim according to these protesters as
insurrections like that were taking
place in state houses all over the
country as dead Christian children were
being mocked while trans activists once
again played the victim merri Garland
and chistopher Ray were deliberately
concealing the shooters motivations and
that's clear now there's no denying it
they were inspiring to lie about one of
the most heinous mass shootings in
modern history and they did it
apparently to protect the narrative that
the B Administration began telling years
ago which is that white supremacy is the
single greatest domestic threat this
country faces anything that does not fit
into that narrative is not allowed to
see the light of day this has been the
marching orders followed at every level
from the doj down to local officials
here in
Nashville so what do we make of all this
I think there are two point point to
keep especially in mind first of all we
don't know what else hail said in her
writings were they mostly rambling and
incoherent that seems likely in fact
that's uh that's true even of the small
portion of the writings that were leaked
they're rambling and and you know the
ramblings of a crazy person was she
motivated primarily by an animist
towards white people despite being white
herself again we don't know for sure but
it also seems likely that anti-white ISM
was not the sole driver of this massacre
or even the main driver but what we can
very safely assume is that her
anti-white rhetoric is certainly a major
factor in why they chose to keep this
material a secret the powers that be do
not want us to have any conversation
about the catastrophic results of the
rampant ubiquitous anti-white rhetoric
coming from every corner of
society the fact is that you can go to
any major institution any University any
major mediet any corporate HR seminar
any leftwing protest Etc and you will
hear whiteness talked about like it's a
disease a Scourge a a cancer to be
eradicated and this idea is entirely
mainstream open rabid genocidal hatred
of whites has been judged completely
acceptable by the
system no matter how much that all did
or didn't play into the attack and
Covenant the fact is that they don't
want us to talk about this problem or
have any conversation about race that
doesn't involve casting white people as
the cartoon villains in the
story and second this is very important
to restate and
emphasize when a mass shooting or
terrorist attack is carried out the
public has a right to know everything
about it how did it happen why what
motivated the killer what intelligence
or law enforcement failures led up to it
all of these questions should be
answered as quickly as possible and if
the shooter dies or commits suicide in
the process of the crime then there's no
conceivable reason to not release all of
this
immediately because there's no criminal
case you're not putting anybody on trial
that person is dead so tell us
everything and tell us right
away the government has no right to keep
this a secret government officials have
no right to decide what bits of
information are relevant to us they
should release all of it
and let us decide what parts matter and
what parts don't that is our
determination to make we should not be
in a position where we have to trust
these people to to to uh use their
judgment to decide what we need to hear
it's not good enough for them to say
well you guys don't need to know about
that why should we trust you about what
we need to
know the other option is secrecy and
lies and
coverups and that's the option that our
leaders choose nearly every time and
especially in this case and when they
choose that option we are left to
speculate left to theorize left to
wonder and fill in the
blanks they leave us to speculate and
then they blame us for
speculating that's the way they've
rigged the
game there's not a lot we can do about
it but we can't ignore their moral
lectures and their
manipulations and we can rest assured in
the fact that we deserve to know the
truth it is really that
simple and now in this case we know at
least some of
it if You' like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there God speed